hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast investigating DNA repair
mechanisms and hypothec brain tumors and
the link to treatment resistance
presented by Sophie Coleman's
fourth-year PhD student Institute of
Integrative Biology University of
Liverpool I'm Alexis Corrales of lappers
and I'll be our moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by laberd's and sponsored
by thermo Fisher Scientific for more
information on our sponsor please visit
thermo Fisher calm now let's get started
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click on
the send button or if there's many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentations
please click on the support tab found at
the top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the answer question box located on the
far left of your screen this
presentation is educational and must
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit
I'd like to now introduce our presenter
sophie comon sophie is passionate about
understanding how the tumor micro
environment can influence DNA repair
which is the focus of her current
research in 2011 sophie commenced the
BSC and molecular biology at the
university of liverpool in 2012 she was
awarded a competitive scholarship
enabling her to undertake a summer
research internship in the lab of dr.
Jacques Curie investigating the nuclear
pore complex throughout her PhD Sophie's
research primarily utilizes silk culture
techniques gene expression analysis and
advanced confocal microscopy so
investigating DNA repair mechanisms and
hypoxic brain tumors to our complete
biography on our speaker please click on
the speaker biography tab
welcome Sophie you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for that introduction so hello
my name is Sophie and I'm a final year
PhD student in the LM C's group at the
University of Liverpool and I'm here to
talk to you today about my work on the
impacts of hypoxia on DNA brain tumors
so it on DNA repair mechanisms in brain
human so our lab group primarily focuses
on looking at the impacts of hypoxia on
biochemical pathways within cancer cells
and if you'd like to connect with me on
Twitter here's my twitter handle feels
please feel free to follow me if you'd
like so what is hypoxia so the classical
definite hypoxia is that it's the point
at which the demand for oxygen outweighs
the supply so there's basically a
deficit in the oxygen supply to the
environment and there's many examples of
hypoxia such as when you start to walk
up a mountain and you get lower air
pressure with less oxygen available for
you to breathe then you start feeling
unwell and this is our to shoot altitude
sickness and this is because you are
becoming hypoxic also on a more
tissue-specific level in a heart attack
a blood vessel becomes blocked and this
prevents blood flow to a region of the
heart and the cells can start to die due
to the fact that they have no oxygen
available and this is what actually
causes people to die after a heart
attack and the final example I want to
talk about is tumor hypoxia
so tumors in Excel themselves can
experience a hypoxic environment and
this can have a very big impact on how
they respond to treatments so tumor
hypoxia is going to be the focus of this
webinar so when we think of the
structure of a solid tumor we have to
understand that there's actually
gradients throughout the tumor so for
example there's a greedy --nt from the
outside to the center of oxygen with a
high oxygen environment on the outside
and a lower oxygen environment on the
inside for also this pH gradients and
nutrient gradients and so that means
that for cells in the center having a
very different environmental experience
than the cells on the outside and this
can result in the formation of a
necrotic core where cells are more
likely to die in the center due to the
lack of oxygen and nutrients for example
and so our group primarily focuses on
this oxygen gradient where we have high
oxygen in some areas and low oxygen in
other areas and so we actually focus on
hi coccyx tumors so hypoxic tumor
examples include breast cancers led by
cancers and brain tumors for example and
it tends to be the more solid tumors
that are hypoxic so the large solid
tumors
the actual oxygenation of tumors and
general tissues is very dependent on
where it is in the body most of you can
appreciate the fact that in your lungs
that oxygen is probably going to be
higher than other areas of your body
because you're actively breathing oxygen
so we work on brain tumors and in the
brain in the normal environment so fizzy
osseous so that means basically the
normal healthy tissues there's a media
and oxygen concentration of 4.6%
and this can actually go up to about
eight percent depending on what we're
about from the brain you take in the
measurements wrong however in brain
tumors the median oxygen percentage is
actually only one point seven percent so
this is quite low meaning that they're
actually hypoxic compared to the healthy
tissues
so there's a number of causes of tumor
hypoxia so when we think of a truck
solid tumor we have to understand that
these cells are rapidly dividing to form
this mass so the dividing a lot quicker
than normal cells to create the solid
lump basically and so this results in
these long diffusion distances between
cells and vessels because the sets of
vessels can't grow fast enough compared
to the cells so this means that oxygen
in the vessels can't diffuse to the cell
making them hypoxic also the blood
vessels that do form tend to be quite
weak and so this means that the more
more prone to bursting and also becoming
blocked which may result in a specific
area of the tumor having a reduced blood
flow and a reduced oxygen concentration
and oxygen environment so throughout the
tumor the different pockets of different
oxygen concentrations and this is a very
transient process so for example at one
point an area could be quite real oxygen
ated but due to what blood vessel this
can actually dramatically reduced
so there's a number of consequences of
tumor hypoxia particularly from a cancer
perspective and the very very important
consequences when it comes to clinical
treatments so the first this consequence
I'd like to mention is that is this idea
that hypoxic cells are more likely to
invade tissues and for metastasis so
they can travel from the primary tumor
site in bay through local regions of
tissue find food vessels enter them and
travel to a secondary area and form
metastases and this is a very big
problem in the clinic because metastasis
is often the thing that kills people
additionally a second consequence of
tumor hypoxia is resistance to
radiotherapy and chemotherapy so this
means that themselves are being hit with
these anti-cancer treatments but they're
going on to live on and healthily divide
as this this diagram depicts so actually
they can end up forming you know and
further enlarging the tumor is searched
so overall hypoxia has a really big
impact on so many different biochemical
pathways and this really impacts how the
cells behaves and the phenotype of the
cells and when we think of the impact of
hypoxia on biochemical pathways we have
to consider the hypoxia-inducible factor
which is known as hiss so hiss is a
transcription factor which is primarily
responsible for the adaptations to this
low cellular environment so under what
we call nor moxier which is basically a
normal oxygen environment for that cell
or tissue we have these enzymes called
pH DS of prolyl hydroxylase --is which
use molecular oxygen will actually
hydroxylate hiss which then targets here
for destruction so hiss isn't able to
activate hypoxia inducible gene however
under hypoxic conditions the if you
don't have this molecular oxygen
available so then this isn't targeted
for death destruction by hydrolysis and
it can actually go on to activate a
number of different genes involved in
different biochemical processes so for
example a few processes that have has
the ability to induce is for example the
read-through kosis and angiogenesis and
these two processes are very key for
making more blood vessels and making
more boards
cells to try and reoxygenate the cell
and also these metabolic changes such as
switch to glycolysis so here can
actually affect a number of biochemical
pathways within the cell and we don't
yet know how many targets have actually
have and there's a lot of work going on
from the minute to kind of understand
what what is targeted by hiss and how it
is influenced in the expression of genes
and the consequences of that from a
counter perspective so I'm now going to
move on to kind of talk about the brain
tumor models that we use so brain tumor
is a very problematic so the killing
many people and it's really important I
kind of get a better understanding of
brain tumor cell biology so it can
improve treatment methods
so the first tumor that I work on is
Abbott glioblastoma
so this is the most common primary brain
tumor in adults and the survival rate is
very poor so as you can see by the
5-year survival rate it's so poor and
most people actually only survive two
years after diagnosis where is pediatric
regular blastoma
the survival rate is much better but we
have a lot of problems because when we
start to use chemotherapy and
radiotherapy on a child's developing
brain we start to get issues such as
hearing loss and speech problems and
learning difficulties so overall it's
really important that we kind of get a
better understanding of these tumors and
what's going on with themselves and both
of these tumors are very very hypoxic so
when it comes to treating cancers and
treating things like brain tumors we
kind of have a few treatment options so
in general for many depth types of
tumors you kind of follow this pathway
so which involves basically surgically
removing the tumor mass and then
followed by chemotherapy and
radiotherapy and the order of this sort
of treatment can vary and and often
depends on the circumstance and the
cancer type so for wire bus doma
known as GBM we initially tries to
remove the tumor as much as possible and
then we treat with a drug called pea
module amide however the team is online
is not very effective and it's actually
only successful against certain tumors
which have this silenced MGMT enzyme and
this is probably a good explanation as
to why have structure poor survival rate
for the streamer because we have
limited treatment options additionally
we use hyper fractionated with video
therapy in conjunction with the team of
all of my treatments so the we have
fractionated radiotherapy works is that
instead of given a very large dose of
radiotherapy on one day and waiting for
example for a month before you give
another large dose the abscess spit
split that large dose up into small
amount and give it regularly for example
daily over a number of weeks and this is
proved a lot more successful than just
you know radiating on one day as it
really helps to try and remove the
cancer cells and kill the cancer cells
and also seems to be less problematic
with regards to side effects so the
required for service from it robust
illness so MB medulloblastoma we also
try to remove the tumors and we've got a
lot more drug related options to treat
this tumor which is probably why we have
a better survival rate compared to
glioblastoma so also for medulla vessel
we additionally you have structure herbs
fractionated radiotherapy and this kind
of been some recent discussions
particularly MIT media about using this
proton beam therapy so the potential
benefits of proton beam therapy is that
the irradiated volume is much more
specific so this means that we have a
lot less damage to healthy tissues in
the brain so this could potentially help
reduce with all those side effects and
those problems such as hearing loss and
speech defects however there's a lot of
research going on in the minute to try
and understand whether proton beam
therapy actually helped any more than
you know the standard traditional radio
therapy we don't know whether it's
actually more effective at killing the
cancer cells so as I mentioned
previously and it's called a big
consequence of hypoxia and tumor hypoxia
is this resistance to treatment and so
what we wanted to do is want to take our
brain tumor cell line which we work on
and try and understand whether we can
see this resistance phenotype induced by
hypoxia so what we did is we took brain
tumor cell lines for medulloblastoma
cell line incubated it in 1% which in
hypoxia or 21% which we define as nor
mattias or it's
farik oxygen environment for every day
or for five days
then we treated the cells with either a
drug or a radiation and then finally we
reacted cells the viability after the
treatment duration and this is an
example of the data that we obtained so
this is with the topside treatment so
the dark orange bar is nor moxier and as
you can see with the topside treatment
it's around about you know 30% viability
after the treatment and with one day
hypoxia
there's a similar sort of level of
viability
however with five days hypoxia so which
is a much more chronic hypoxic
environment you can see the by abilities
are what high looking at like 70 to 80%
so this is implying in that this hypoxic
environment for five days has made the
cells more resistant to treatment and
what we got from this is the fact that
it requires chronic hypoxic exposure so
a long-term five day exposure to Corbitt
resistance yet acute hypoxia wasn't able
to do this
so when we think of an cancer treatment
we have to consider DNA damage and DNA
repair because many treatments actually
aim to damage DNA repair sorry damaged
the DNA itself and cause DNA repair
pathways to be triggered so here we have
the DNA which is attacked by a drug or
irradiation
and this can create different types of
damage included a break oxidation
hydrolysis and cross-linking and it's
very important to understand what types
of damage is being induced by a drug or
irradiation because these will activate
different repair pathways an overall
went when we're considering repair we
have to understand that DNA repair
mechanisms are really influenced by
genetic background and the cellular
environment and kind of these ideas led
to our research question so what we want
to understand is how it hypoxia
influence in the DNA repair mechanisms
in brain tumors because DNA repair is
highly influenced by cellular
environment so is a low-oxygen cellular
environment impact in the mechanisms and
this is what we'd like to understand
so I'm going to kind of present kind of
two parts of the story and one is a very
very specific story looking at a double
strand break recognition in
medulloblastoma whereas the second part
is very much ongoing work looking at
multiple repair pathways which are down
regulated by hypoxia so moving on to
part one so what we decided to do is
we've seen this cream and resistance
this being a type of resistance in
hypoxia we wanted to know what was
causing that so we decided to do a
microarray experiment it's the cell so
this is with medulloblastoma cells we
put them in hypoxia over varying time
points and what we found is that many
genes were actually regulated at reached
a time point and in the literature it's
often described that hypoxia has the
ability to induce the expression of
multi-drug resistance genes so MDR so
what we thought was okay so maybe this
this resistance phenotype is actually
due to the induction of moisture
resistance genes so we took our
microarray data and pulled out the
expression level of three key motor
resistance genes however what we found
is that none of these genes were induced
by hypoxia therefore if this resistance
phenotype was not related to multi-drug
resistance so this needles think okay so
as treatment causes DNA damage maybe
something's going on with a DNA repair
mechanisms so we specifically took the
expression profiles for a number of DNA
repair pathways so for example the
non-homologous end joining pathway and
homologous recombination repair so both
of these and repair pathways involved in
the repair of double strand breaks so
the non-homologous end joining is
primarily in G naught and G 1 whereas
have knowledge of recombination is in S
phase in G 2 when there's a smaller DNA
strand available so we looked at the
expression and we found that a lot of
the genes were strongly regulated at
later time point and hypothesis for more
chronic environments and in particular
we found that there was a clear down
regulation in key genes involved in
double strand break recognition so I'm
going to kind of start
plane of how double-strand breaks are
recognized and homologous recombination
pathway so here we have the DNA double
helix which is attacked by a drug or
radiation and it took us from great
forms and this basically means that both
strands of the DNA have completely
severed so this is the most lethal type
of DNA damage to a cell and one double
strand braid can actually kill a cell
so the initial set of double strand
break repair is recognition and this is
done by the mrn complex which is
basically recruited to the site of
damage
so the mrn complex is made up of
midbrain or NBN MRA 11 and rad 50 and
the role of these proteins is to
initially sense the damage they are DNA
damage sensors so next in the pathway is
recruitment of signal transducers and in
particular the signal transducer ATM
which reduces to the site of damage from
phosphor related which activates its
kinase abilities so ATM is then able to
either phosphorylate carbonate which
will lead to repair such as check two
and then the third DNA damage will group
repaired by the homologous recombination
pathway or alternatively it can force
the cells into an apoptosis pathway by a
p53 so in summary we have the double
strand break formation we have the breat
recognition we have the signal
transduction via ATM then either we have
the repair or apoptosis
so as I mentioned previously we have six
down-regulation in some of the key
components of the mrn Complex
responsible for recognition of breaks so
we took our micro radiator and found
this and then we decided to work using a
real-time PCR and clearly here you can
see this nibaran and this MRE eleven are
down regulated by hypoxia whereas this
red fist it isn't we wanted to see
whether this was purely due to the fact
that it was at least a time point or
maybe earlier time points would trigger
this however you know six hours you
don't really see the sound regulation
and who you get to the later time point
like 48 hours plus so it is more of a
chronic thing more of a chronic hypoxic
exposure that is caused in this this
down regulation and as this was all at
the gene expression level and obviously
repair is always with proteins we needed
to check the protein levels of these key
DNA repair proteins so we did wet them
well and as you can see here particular
with the quantification this clear down
regulation of both nibaran and MRE 11 at
the protein level and it's mirroring the
gene expression data so what we have is
this down regulation of this double
strand break recognition complex which
is kind of the very key and initial step
in the repair pathway so we wanted to
see whether ATM was affected so the next
step in the pathway and whether the
activation of the ATM via this
phosphorylation is impacted by hypoxia
and indeed it was so as you can see by
this Western blot so in the 21 percent
we've got a nice amount of ATM and a
nice amount of phosphate a.m. and then
at 1% it starts to decrease and when you
go to even more severe hypoxic
environment it's even more decreased
than that and you can see this by the
quantification so clearly particularly
in the total ATM levels you see this
nice down regulation which increases
with the severity of hypoxia so this
kind of made us think it's APM's also
affected maybe p53 defective and maybe
any effects on p53 is really impacting
how there is the cells are responding
and maybe contributing to resistance
so we looked at the induction of the
targets of p53 so your kin at this Pima
mdm2 and p21 so this is the mRNA level
and what we found in high pops if it was
less activation of p53 target and we
think this is primarily due to the fact
that in hypoxia is less fuss the p53 so
that means that these less stable Clifty
p53 available
so in summary what does this all mean so
under hypoxic conditions in our material
blastoma cell line we have the sound
regulation of the double strand break
recognition complex which also leads on
to the ATM being down regulated and a
reduced activation of ATM and we don't
have stable p53 and activation of p53
targets so what we think is happening is
that these cells will start sensing the
damage and recognizing that its presence
therefore they're not trigger in
apoptosis and so the cells are still
surviving and this is what we think is
explaining the truth and resistance
phenotype that we observed however this
mechanism although it's very good at
explaining how this treatment resistance
may occur this wasn't very Universal and
it wasn't in all our cell lines and it
wasn't in all our cell types and in
particularly once it's kind of further
investigate the effects of hypoxia and
glioblastoma so we decided to kind of
take a step back and look to have a more
global view of what's happening to the
DNA repair genes under hypoxic
environment so this leads on to part two
where I'm going to talk about and data
from multiple repair pathways but I'm
going to focus in on the error-prone
double strand break repair pathways or
non-homologous end joining so for what
we decide to do which we decided to
incubate a number of M ribosome
ourselves in different oxygen conditions
so normal to which is 20 rumsen 1% which
you could define as moderate hypoxia and
then more severe hypoxia which is more
point 1 percent and then we extracted
RNA from these cells and we subject them
to another string experiment so a nano
strange experiment basically enables you
to look at the gene expression of the
number of genes in a single reaction so
we decided to look at 108 to DNA repair
genes in many different types of DNA
repair pathways and today I'm going to
focus on at non-homologous end joining
so how does non-homologous end joining
words so we have a double strand break
and as I said before non-homologous end
joining is only in gene or and g1 so it
doesn't have the requirement of a
homologous strands to be present so we
have this double strand break the end of
process through the recruitment as to
kind of key protein complexes so 2:17
qat initially and then DNA PKS
and then this goes on to further end
processing by xrc t4 and then ligation
of the strands back together by ligase
boss this is quite a simple DNA repair
pathway it basically just sticks the
ends back together and can actually
cause quite a lot of errors in the
sequence so when we actually look at the
data for the expression of these genes
what we find is that leg is four is
strongly down regulated by hypoxia and
this down regulation actually increases
with increase in severity of hypoxia and
we found this in nearly all of our
glioblastoma cell lines so when we look
back at the pathway here we have this
like a four which is down regulated
shown by the red arrow and therefore we
think that maybe the strands of DNA
aren't actually being joined back
together as we should we wanted to kind
of look at the the kind of the
consequences of this and what what was
going to be happening in this situation
and what would this mean for the cells
so we decided to take a lifestyle
imaging approach to look at repair
protein recruitment so what this
involves is basically we tagged a DNA
repair proteins with a GFP molecule so
we can visualize this on a microscope
transect to enter cells and then we
radiate the cells with a multiple term
laser and the most important laser has
the capability of inducing double strand
breaks to the DNA and a very specific
defined region so here we have examples
for example the nucleus which is green
due to the fact that we've got a GFP DNA
repair protein and then we choose a
specific region of interest to blast
with the laser and then what we should
hopefully see is basically an increase
in intensity of the GFP signal at the
site of damage as the protein is
actually recruiting to the double strand
break and trying to repair them to your
fetus increased intensity so you're now
going to see a video kind of explained
in this and hopefully you'll be able to
really visualize this increase in
intensity over time
what we can basically to do is we can
actually measure this so we can romesha
the kinetics of the initial increase in
the protein signal so in the GFP signal
and it appears that between hypoxia
normal fear the actual initial
recruitment of protein is very very
similar however at least a time point
you can see this deviation between the
two lines where hypoxia seems to be kind
of the protein seems to be remaining
there and not being lost so it's not
dissociating from the brief and this
could suggest that the repair is less
efficient in hypoxia and this work is
very very much ongoing and that in the
coming months we hope to kind of
understand this a little bit further and
kind of keep this on to later time
courses to really understand whether
that protein isn't dissociated in front
from the damaged site
so what we found is we found a number of
other changes in hypoxia for multiple
DNA repair pathways so I've just shown
you non-homologous end referring it as
an example however you know we found
changes in mismatch repair base excision
repair homologous recombination repair
for example and we want to kind of
understand what is the functional impact
of these changes what does this mean for
DNA repair and what does this mean for
the cells so to do this we kind of use
multiple methods so for example
classical biochemistry techniques such
as Western blots in qPCR then we've also
employed our microscopy technique using
this laser for damage and finally we've
started to use a thing called the comet
assay which is a very traditional assay
used in DNA repair studies so I'm going
to talk to you briefly about what the
comet assay is and how it works and how
it can be very very useful to look at
DNA repair kinetics so how the comet
assay work is you take some cells you
treat them with either drugs or
irradiation and then you mix those cells
with low melting point agarose and put
that blob of cells and agarose onto a
microscope slide then you apply electric
current through through the agarose very
similar to how you would with PCR and
gel electrophoresis and then you stain
the DNA and you can visualize it on a
microscope so for example here in the
untreated you get this really nice tight
circle of DNA whereas in the treated you
get what looks like a comment which
gives the assay its name so you get a
nice little tight circle at one end
which is the head end however then you
get this like balloon shape at the back
and this is due to the fact that the DNA
has breaks and because the electric
currents been applied it's allowed the
DNA to migrate through the gel and this
kind of gives us an idea of the extent
of damage within the cells and so what
we can do is we can use this to
understand how long it takes to repair
that damage so for example you take some
untreated cells and then some treated
cells so you can see on treated is very
circular whereas the treat even more
like comic sheet but you can allow the
cells to repair after treatment so for
example 30 minutes after repair you can
see a few comets are still there but
they're a little bit smaller
at 60 minutes at the pair it's basically
reverse you back to the untreated so
this gives them the timeframe of how
long it takes for these cells to repair
and what we want to do is compare
normalcy and hypoxia and see whether
this time period changes and that will
give us a very good indication of how
effective the DNA repair mechanisms are
especially when all these changes to the
DNA repair genes and proteins have
occurred in hypoxia so to summarize this
part what we've seen is multiple pets
DNA repair pathways are down regulated
by hypoxia and glioblastoma cell lines
we really want to kind of answer this
question of what are the consequence of
these changes and to do this we use in a
number of methods including the live
cell imaging looking at the DNA repair
protein recruitment and dissociation and
also this comment aspect to look at the
DNA repair kinetics
so this is very much work to be
continued and we hope to get some more
answers in the next few months
so in summary not all cells were
responding to hypoxia in the same way
when it comes to the changes to DNA
repair mechanisms and this is very
important because from a clinical
perspective perspective we really need
to understand how distant cell types are
responding to hypoxia and how this might
affect how they respond to treatment so
today I've presented you two potential
mechanisms which are induced by hypoxia
so for the first looking at the down
regulation of double strand break
recognition and the final one looking a
bit more broad looking at multiple DNA
repair pathways so the next step from
this a really to kind of understand how
are these changes in the DNA repair
proteins regulated by hypoxia what is
directly mechanistically causing these
changes so in the literature when you
look at changes to DNA repair proteins
by hypoxia it's kind of three main
qualities so the first is this direct
reduction of gene expression so
something's action that promoter to
reduce the expression or alternatively
it could be epigenetic changes or even
post translational modifications of the
DNA repair proteins in kind of the
overriding question is is the
hypoxia-inducible factor here involved
in this story and these are the sort of
questions that we hope to answer in the
next few months because if we truly
understand the mechanism behind these
regulations then we can actually start
to manipulate the system and manipulate
the pathways to try and kind of
understand it further to try and improve
treatment methods so I really hope
you've enjoyed gaining an insight into
how we look at hypoxia and brain tumors
in their DNA repair mechanisms thank you
very much for listening I'm more than
happy to take any questions thank you
Thank You Sophie for your informative
presentations we will now start a live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the answer question
box located on the far left of your
screen one of there's many of your
questions as we have time for so let's
get started
our first question is
why is acute hypoxia not sufficient to
induce these changes
so the answer this isn't it very simple
unfortunately and it's very dependent on
which changes we're talking about
so some changes we do see in acute time
points whereas some more at a later time
point and we think this is because that
long-term hypoxia is inducing many
genetic changes such as epigenetic
modifications that require a time period
for those to occur which results in the
changes to the DNA repair mechanisms
that we see so the answer isn't so clear
cut but we have some ideas as to why
that might happen
okay Sophie our next question is how did
you make all of these measurements under
hypoxic conditions or after bringing the
samples out of the one percent o2
environment into room air
so we are actually fortunate enough to
have what's called a hypoxic glove box
so this is an incubator where you can
actually put your hands in it and
culture cells within the actual chamber
so they are maintained within the
hypoxic environment so this means that a
lot of the analysis that we have done
such as the testing the different drugs
and things like that has been done under
the hypoxic environment there is some
experiments where the ROS a period of
reoxygenate however we think this impact
is very small because a lot of the
changes that we see to DNA repair
mechanisms and maintained for a period
of time after oxygenation
so the second part to the question so
I'll assume you did all these
measurements analysis experiments in
room air after bringing the samples out
of the incubator so wouldn't it be more
accurate to describe these results as
being potentially a result of
reoxygenate
as opposed to hypoxia alone so and it's
yeah it's very important to consider the
fact that sometimes we have we
oxygenation however as I said before a
lot of the experiments are done under
permanent hypoxic conditions and however
when we do have real oxygenation we try
and account for that by allowing the
cells - equilibria
so that any oxygen if damage is repaired
for it for example but most of our
experiments are done on there are
hypoxic environments
my next question how are these change
DNA repair genes regulated in hypoxia
so that's kind of the big question that
we're trying to answer at the minute and
there's many documented pathways that
result in DNA repair gene regulation and
hypoxia however it appears to be
different for each different type of
gene each different pathway as well so
these some suggestions that either via
hit a direct mechanism of his-- for
example impacting the promoter at the
genes
however these other mechanisms where you
know it's completely independent and fit
and this is something that we really
want to explore because as soon as we
understand how genes are regulated we
can maybe start thinking about how to
target these mechanisms for therapeutic
benefits
do you think this could have an impact
on the way we treat these tumors in the
clinic that's the ultimate hope and
because so when we think of the clinic
we have to understand that all these
drugs that they using in the clinic so
these tumors are actively damaging the
DNA and if those tumors are hypoxic
something is going to happen to those
DNA repair mechanisms which really might
impact how those tumors are responding
to the treatment so we really do hope
that we're going to you know develop
this further in it'll kind of give us a
better understanding of what's going on
in these tumors and then we can maybe
translate this into the clinic in the
future
so here our next question hypoxia can
affect the cell cycles do you see this
in two results could this have an impact
on your findings
so in the literature is quite well
documented that hypoxia does have an
effect on the cell cycle but what we
found is that this is actually very cell
type-specific so a study from our lab
looks at glioma cells or took lots of
cell lines as well as primary cells from
that have been taken from tumors and we
found that actually hypoxia did not have
an impact on the cell cycle and this is
really important finding because when
you have impacts on cell cycle this can
alter the response to drugs because
often the killing mechanism of drugs
requires cycling cells so our cells
aren't actually impacted as with regard
to the cell cycle and hypoxia which is a
positive thing
and Sophie it looks like we have time
for one more question some drugs don't
work as well in hypoxia so do you know
if you are getting the same amount of
damage in the hypoxic cells as the
coccyx cells
yeah that's a very important question so
what we do is we actually use the comet
assay which I've described in the talk
and to measure the level of damage that
we're achieving in the cells and we
found that with most of our drugs that
we use we do get the same amount of
damage in hypoxic cells as normal Excel
however the some drugs that we don't
work in hypotheses so we have to do
these treatments out of a hypoxic
chamber and we have to consider you know
the impact of the oxygenation within
that experimental setup so yeah we kind
of do look into that and it's a very
important thing to consider
thank you again soapy do you have any
final comments for our audience now just
to say thank you very much for listening
everybody enjoyed the webinar
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of the registration we would like
to thank laberd's and our sponsor Thermo
Fisher Scientific for underwriting
today's educational webcast this webcast
can be viewed on-demand through October
of 2018 laberd's will alert you via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye
you